[Music]
a heartbroken family still trying to
pull themselves together after a
horrible loss months after their dream
wedding their daughter and her wife torn
apart in a deadly crash christian
casadas joining us now live in studio
and i understand you spoke to the family
tonight about how they're trying to heal
both emotionally and financially that's
right denise well the harkness family
tells us they are living in alternate
realities instead of celebrating their
daughter kaylie's six-year anniversary
with her partner ivana they are dealing
with doctors medical bills and funeral
services
she just said mom she was my person
she was my best friend
and she says i don't know who i am
without her a dream wedding cut short
for kaylie and ivana about five months
after the couple celebrated this special
moment the unthinkable happened we know
that a commercial
concrete truck
was broke down and we know that that
effectively
choked the lanes down to one lane we
know that they never
they never
understood the danger the harkness tells
us both ladies were driving home from
work on the 2 15 near sky point on
saturday when they crashed 26 year old
kaylee was quickly hospitalized but 30
year old ivana didn't survive compound
fractures in both ankles
a fracture below her knee
rods plates
as the family prepares for kaylie's
physical recovery they are also
preparing for heavy medical bills a
difficult road without kaylie's special
person i also spoke with ivana's parents
and they just want everybody to know
that she was their princess
well the family tells us the young
couple was planning on having kids the
mother also started a gofundme to help
kaylee with her financial recovery we
have all that information on our website
8newsnow.com if you at home would like
to help christian casa is live local now